all right b Diddy can I call you b Diddy
does that even make sense in the rap
World B shapir what do we what you know
do you have a rap name it's it's Dr
drel but you know will this be my career
going forward I I I have doubts I don't
know I feel myself already drawn to the
lifestyle I spent the weekend clubbing
yeah as as as we as we Orthodox Jews
do I was out at I was out at the clubs
sipping the Henny I was gonna say is
kavas is cavasier kosher I'm not so sure
I can feel myself being dragged down
into into a morass of of this rap
hip-hop lifestyle and uh the other night
my family had to sit me down for an
intervention and they had to tell me
that it was time to it might be time to
move on Beat It Up Nord catch a charge
extra large and extra hard put this p
word right in your face swipe your nose
like a credit card